Oh what's going on YouTube check it out
I'm coming back for another one and
listen I thought that it was over after
the Asian stereotypes win but I guess
it's not because I'm here again
[ __ ] a lot of people haven't
said any messages saying that oh my god
white people so racist look at what they
say to me well guess what I'm gonna be
kind of honest with you I don't think
white people are the most racist people
of all I just think that they don't know
how to phrase their questions or words
correctly so why people your boy got you
back here I'm here to help you out LG
ass and let's get it let's go number one
do not assume that an Asian person does
not speak English and you know what is
that offensive that you assume it it's
offensive because the way you go about
for example how come every time somebody
assumes I don't speak English they speak
the language a lot louder as if I would
understand it more excuse me sir
you lost your are you are you lost or
are you a [ __ ] if I don't speak English
the volume of the language is not the
problem do you understand this lazy
camber look yeah you get ya know huh my
daughter huh no I'm but I dried up then
there are those of you who start
speaking to us like we're lost child
honey you lost somewhere how did you
wanna you want to go get honey take your
come here get the hell's wrong with you
Barlow here's another tip do not try to
relate to us about our food this is a
true story I was at the post office not
too long ago and there was a white man
standing next to me and then you know we
were kind of standing a lot doing our
own thing the first thing he says to me
goes it's a long long yeah JG yes oh
yeah I just had some chow mein yesterday
she was great yeah yeah man look up
don't ask us where the best Asian
restaurants are how am I supposed to
know Boba's beside me that thing into
thing white people we got you full do
you know why do you be alive that you're
paying top dollar for food that's made
in a third-world country huh
biggest pet peeve stop asking me how to
say [ __ ] in my language and this goes
for white people and other Asian people
to stop that [ __ ] hey David how do you
say uh how was your day in Korean okay
oh you want to know how to say how was
your day in Korean are you listening
carefully Issa ha wasn't your day do you
know what's worse than that when you
learn a few words in our language and
then you cost
they use it to try to impress us hey
David I'm no ha failure and I don't want
you to look Craig you know why cuz I
already know why you're learning cuz
you're trying to steal our women's stop
gifts in what area of Asia were from cuz
you're gonna get it round you should
already know this by default don't get
Chinese foot butter what about snow am I
supposed to guess huh [ __ ] don't get it
all it's not a carnival game you're not
gonna get tokens popping out of my hands
later fool I don't expect you to know
and I'm not gonna hate you if you don't
know my nationality I swear every time
somebody thinks they see a group of
Asians is jeopardy or something like you
gotta gets it right to win a prize so
must be Cambodian a little darker than
usual last but not least if you're
traveling to Asia do not ask me what
parts you should visit lookie here
player most likely where we live is not
what you want to go I don't even know
why you want to visit a country that we
all escaped thousands of Asians are
trying to leave and y-axes up here try
to sneak your ass in well let's see how
the Pokemon move over there so my Asian
brothers and sisters out there the next
time you think of white versus racist
just think about what the same because I
really don't think that they are they're
just trying to be a little bit more
culturally understanding they don't
understand how to go about so why people
I forgive you I forgive you Oh David you
don't like white people let me tell you
something I love white people if I don't
like my people I would be in this
country because you know they took out
all the Native Americans when smallpox
II oh that's not funny
Clemens is coming for it
are you recording though oh my god David